we did this event on saturday we had a
bunch of people come out and someone
asked me about joe rogan and they said
they felt like joe rogan was letting us
down in terms of the culture war and
standing up for freedom and stuff you
know i basically was like dude joe rogan
has done more for freedom than you know
almost anyone else and it's he's an
incredibly powerful voice in media that
you know we're grateful to have but
i will say you know i was disappointed
that he performed at madison square
garden over the vax mandate he says he's
against it but here we go and then we
were actually just talking before the
show about cn about cnn with sanjay
gupta and then michael malus
we were talking about how
you know uh rogan called don lemon a
dumb mother effort
yep and then cnn tripled down but you
were you're you're mentioning to us
about how he was defending cnn even yeah
i mean joe rogan clearly has a personal
relationship with jeff zucker who runs
cnn uh but before he ran cnn he was he
headed up nbc when joe rogan was was you
know doing fear factor over there and
you know on one hand i respect that you
know joe rogan has a personal
relationship with somebody doesn't
immediately want to like throw them
under the bus but on the other hand
i don't know what to say i mean he was
saying lots of things along the lines of
you know well media are important you
know we've got to you know work with
these you know people we've got to deal
with this
and it was just like completely
conflicting like on one hand they have
literally just personally attacked him
slandered him on air i've said things
that were patently untrue about what he
did um you know i mean the ivor mexican
thing was insane i mean the guy also
took monoclonal antibodies which is like
the standard medical therapeutic
why does why doesn't he why doesn't he
sue
well that's a really good question i
mean i we really need more people that
can stand up and challenge media
organizations in ways that it's going to
make them hurt uh i've written a lot
about this before where you know the
media and this america have you know
amazing libel protections um it's very
hard to sue a media company especially
if you're a a public figure and you know
do anything with that um and for a long
time i think that was a source of pride
in this country you know in the uk and
other countries you know there are a lot
of frivolous libel lawsuits but we've
kind of gone to the extreme like i think
maybe 60 years ago there was a big
public interest in protecting large
media organizations they were doing
important you know corruption reporting
and things like that at a time when
there weren't a lot of alternatives to
do media stuff now increasingly you see
things like the covington kid incident
um you know just really capricious mean
stuff um coming from the media directed
by people clearly for political
motivations where they're using these
libel laws uh as a as a sword rather
than a shield i mean they know they
can't be sued or they know it's gonna be
difficult or costly to sue them so
they're just aggressively going after
people in ways that are brutally unfair
you were saying before that times v
sullivan was kind of assuming that the
the media organizations were going to be
ethical and maintain that and which was
always kind of a bad assumption but it
was a much better assumption 60 years
ago than it is now when clearly they
just aren't i mean if you see what goes
on uh you know in cnn or any frankly
major news organization where the new
york times editorial staff literally
says words or violence i mean that is
not a regime that we can prop up you
know under the color of you know law um
you know that needs to ordinary citizens
need and and even public figures like
joe rogan need to have an opportunity to
go after these people and stop them from
doing that stuff again give them an
incentive bloody their nose say don't
lie about me again when did the media
become such an obvious
propaganda machine and i don't mean just
i don't mean just politically i mean you
look at rotten tomatoes right the film
death wish with bruce willis
this is a studio phone this is a
a-listing a-lister hollywood celeb
but death which got panned by critics
because they called it a gun nut
masturbation film right and it wasn't it
was a it was a revenge film like any
other action film but they went nuts on
it and that said to me it's not about
making money
for hollywood it's about making sure
only specific ideologies get the
promotion from the machine i think it's
jon stewart jack posobik said this on
the show last week that jon stewart
basically weaponized comedy and politics
and combined them and i was like i love
jon stewart it hurt to hear that but
before that it didn't exist and after
that it started to we also have to admit
that this is their greatest weapon but
it's also their their greatest weakness
because the more disingenuous the more
they lie the more they just make stuff
up and attack
children or or grandmothers who meme at
their door and try to dox them like cnn
did the more they just become more and
more outrageous the more people realize
hey this is this is getting to a really
sick level and we need some alternatives
here immediately and they will turn to
alternatives the onion kind of started
at two the when people saw how popular
it was to just say things that were
patently false and like put a little
disclaimer at the bottom be like by the
way this is all a joke
it was
dangerous you know dangerous yeah i
think for a long time you know we had a
healthier culture in the sense that
there was kind of a cultural realm and
there was a political realm and there
was a little bit of overlap as there
always was but by and large those things
were kept separate and i you know i
don't know i mean it's sort of the
post-modern influence i think just
everything got crazy meta
like andrew barbara used to say you know
politics is downstream from culture and
that's that's true to a large extent and
there was this kind of like meta
realization across the board that that
was the case so all of a sudden the
narratives and culture literally became
the quote-unquote narrative meaning that
they realized they could use that to
control things politically so you know
in the case of dune or something we
can't just talk about how house
harkonnen you know is an interesting
metaphor that might have some salience
for our political situation or whatever
it immediately becomes a you know a
method of attack for tim simply because
he didn't enjoy a movie you know it's it
everything is political now yeah well it
was funny because breitbart said
politics is downstream from culture then
we started hearing the social justice
activists the woke saying that the the
culture is political
or the cultural is political and then
you have people pushing back saying no
it's not and i'm like it is i i think we
should take breitbart statement one step
further and say politics does not even
matter
the way i explained this before is uh
here's here's an example you know you
ever see those book wacky laws yeah
there's like
laws from the 1800s where it's like no
apple pies cooling on the windowsill on
tuesday at 7 pm
never going to be in force today why
culture
the politics the legislation the laws
are completely meaningless
now to a certain extent that's i'm
obviously being a little hyperbolic
if there's something on the books and
we're like i disagree with this law and
then they're going to be like yeah well
you know the law is the law and you're
going ah i guess
however over time when culture changes
those laws become completely meaningless
and they can remain in the books and
politicians politicians can say that you
can't do that people do it anyway
so if that's the case then culture is
everything and if we're not advocating
for freedom and liberty and pushing back
against authoritarianism then you will
live in authoritarian woke matrix
and that's where the the the the
democrats the the people who live in
these bubbles the activists screaming at
this guy at the dave chappelle thing
they live in the social credit system
you can choose to live in it or you can
choose to walk away but right now we're
seeing it get bigger and bigger and dave
chappelle has just been flunked out of
the social credit system
yeah i think i think there's a lot of
truth to what you just said
i mean the whole point of the way the
american political system was set up
previously it was to be a quote unquote
limited government precisely because
they expected everyone to live basically
the full spectrum of their lives in the
cultural sphere
and now
you can't get away
i mean and and that is in and of itself
very much a form of tyranny you know
we're we're basically two separate
cultures demanding each other abide by
the rules of the other and that can't
that is untenable at least two the court
of public opinion is so real they uh and
now that everyone's in public it's like
it's like the evolution of law like like
obviously if
beaumarshay for instance i don't know if
you guys are familiar with him he's a
french revolutionary basically aided the
americans and was like the number one
french guy that helped she'd be
considered one of the founding fathers
he got into legal trouble but because he
was such a celebrity they just
overlooked it let him out um and that
and what we saw
maybe with what we're gonna see with
alec baldwin like what we saw with uh
uh what the the guy that kneeled on
george floyd's neck i mean that was
public opinion that was uh a court of
public opinion the translation right now
so we'll see what happens so the laws
they write them down on paper but in
reality it's what the people feel and
say and do that matters and we have to
add another layer to this that that is
also manipulated because when you look
at what's promoted highlighted on social
media what's shown to you first it's the
ideas that they want you to believe in
so if they want to make everyone feel
that everyone's outraged about this
specific thing they're only going to be
showing you that on social media to the
point where it actually creates that
situation because everyone's going to
see this is what people are doing i want
to fit in i want to be normal i'm going
to be doing this as well so i would
actually point at big tech social media
as being far more responsible at setting
the culture then of course the
mainstream media less and less people
are watching the mainstream media less
and less people are watching jimmy
fallon and stephen colbert people hate
to be lectured to people hate to be
preached too and that's exactly what the
mainstream media does i mean just a
couple years ago i remember leno and
letterman and and the way i remember
them is that they would make fun of the
democrats and the republicans they would
talk about celebrity gossip nonsense
they would rarely get as political as
the current commentators do now to the
point where we have all these
commentators saying the same thing at
the same time slot with very little
political difference uh because they're
literally preaching establishment uh
bootlicking talking points if we see a
fascist dictatorship over take over it's
going to be corporate
of course yes without a doubt the
corporatocracy the the multinational
corporations they're the ones
essentially here creating not only the
esg score that that we talked about with
jack posobik when he was on the show
this is a very important social credit
score the corporate social credit score
these are the people calling the shots
here and with them calling the shots
they not just they don't just implement
this they create this idea that this is
popular this is what this is public
opinion they shape public opinion by by
pretending that it is reality when in
the beginning phases it's not thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to watch
live you can check out this channel
monday through friday at 8 00 pm and
don't forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you